you recently learned from women on our
panel about sexual harassment
while we have victims or survivors
coming forward and saying me too we need
men to say I did that you we need men to
step forward and to see themselves in
these stories and where are the men at
this roundtable that can come and and
contribute their voices as well
well that was Teen Vogue editor in chief
Elaine welter author her invitation for
men to join the conversation did not go
unanswered a group of five very
accomplished men recently took up the
epidemic of sexual intimidation in a
conversation with Alex Wagner Alex joins
us at the table really looking forward
to hearing what they had to say he had a
lot of really interesting two things to
say good morning guys the men we met
with as he said Gail they're all leaders
in their field and they are in positions
to empower women the group included
writer director and producer Judd Apatow
fashion designer proble Goran former
astronaut and sexual assault survivor
Leland Melvin New York giant Mark
Herzlich whose wife is also a survivor
of child abuse and domestic violence and
celebrity chef and restauranteur Tom
Colicchio all of them spoke about moving
the meaty movement forward and its
impact on them and their industries as
you watch these stories unfold every day
there is a new story there is a new
Washington Post story a New York Times
story there's a story on the Internet
I'm sure for a lot of men there's fear
right where are you guys as this all
unfolds done it's certainly a tidal wave
that that's happening but I look at it
like it's in it amazing that so many
people have felt the need to be silent
for so long how terrible must the
environment be that right now as a
result of the internet and as a result
of just you know confluence of events
people feel safe speaking up just this
week ken Friedman Mario Batali
high-profile restauranteurs
go down and yet kitchens are places
where this behavior has gone unchecked
for decades mmm so what's the answer
here at home I think you're right it has
been going on for decades and I think
the answer is and I think we're seeing
the answer
there's a cultural shift happening right
before our eyes right now and that's
where the struggle is but until we take
it a step further and say what can we do
in our industry to make sure those women
not only are safe but economically there
are structures in place that Beck
actually can can can see them thrive men
are kind of grouped together from a very
young age and whether it's you know
athletic teams or in locker rooms or
fraternities where you're amongst a
collective group of men there becomes a
vernacular that is negative towards
women and there becomes an expectation
of other men to place ideology on
conquering women and Leyland I mean that
brings to the fore the question of sort
of masculinity and how young men are
indoctrinated at an early age and you've
written about this me too and when I was
five years old and these you know older
kids decided hey we're gonna have fun
with this young little boy and you know
I I talk about this in my book because
it's like how can I help other kids get
over this but there's so many kids that
are abused they end up some are abusers
themselves or alcoholics or just
whatever happens to them after that
expect if they don't get help
did you ask yourself those questions
though about you know how can i how
could I have let this happen to me
I mean how I did yeah I blame myself I
shouldn't have gone over there I
shouldn't have I should have fought I
should have done something differently
and I think that's that part of the
shame that builds in us it causes cancer
yeah that if you don't get it out or
have a vehicle to have someone to talk
to
we talked about a lot of this aggression
in the context of the victims and one of
the reasons we wanted to have men talk
about this is because really men are
part of the solution right and yet so
much of this conversation is among and
for women what is that about problem I
don't think men are the solution I
really don't think so I think the I
think that needs to be shift in a
thinking of like treating women as a
weaker sex that they need to be
protected somehow and I'm very fortunate
enough to be surrounded by extremely
strong women in my life you know who who
don't put up with any of these kind of
stuff and you know so I think a man's
role becomes
a lot about listening let me listen to
women not just white women women of
color with trans women all women across
Judd you are surrounded by women at home
what has it been like to be in your
house at this moment I mean I have a lot
of emotions about it I feel you know a
lot of sorrow for my daughters to face a
world that is often dangerous and for a
very long time you know we talked about
you know how do you stay safe and also
expecting young men boys to be
respectful like what do you what do you
want from relationships what do you want
from these interactions you want to be
treated well and if people don't treat
you well they should not be in your
world in any way and I think that too
often men especially when they're around
women with the really concern is being
humiliated in front of women and that's
where a lot of this starts and so trying
to teach them that that you know a girl
in your class is strong and it's smart
and and that's okay that shouldn't
humiliate you you don't you don't have
to be better than everybody when you
talk about a woman's perspective mark
your wife is a victim of abuse and was
silent about it for a very long time
what didn't she teach you about the
issue
my wife has you know domestic violence
in her house when she was when she was
younger and she really didn't share it
for for many years until she you know
felt comfortable around a man for the
first time which was with me and it was
interesting at that time in my life I
was diagnosed with bone cancer and I was
going through radiation and chemotherapy
my future was looking pretty bad and
when she felt comfortable enough to to
tell me about the violence that had
occurred to her it was it was
interesting how all those things didn't
matter anymore didn't matter how I
looked or how I felt I felt more like a
man in that moment because it was
creating a safe environment for
another human what should happen to the
men who have been accused of sexual
predation and harassment should you be
allowed to have your career back I'm
least interested in what is going to
happen to this men what I'm interested
in is how are we going to empower women
how are we going to change the
conversation you know the Luisi caves of
the world may not work again because we
know him the idea of him actually going
out there and doing something I think is
gonna be rejected by society but what
about what about what about that that
that chef who's working at some
third-rate hotel in Nebraska somewhere
who sexually harassed women's gets outed
I'll just move it to another town and no
one's gonna know his face and he'll get
a job so to some degree this is a
conversation about who has power and how
power is wielded and who that doesn't do
anything you know Harvey whines he's
writing checks to people Frank look guys
he's writing checks to people and
because he's still making a lot of money
that the powerful people they're just
saying this is too much of a pain in the
ass for me to become the person to shut
it down right it's a culture change it's
a movement and you know the civil rights
movement didn't end when we signed the
voters Rights Act or Civil Rights Act
it's it's still continuing and so I
think this is culturally present right
now and I think it's something that
we're focused on now but this is gonna
take generations to actually fix we
spent nearly an hour talking with these
men and could easily have talked for an
hour more all of them were passionate
about this issue and felt not only a
duty to be engaged on the issue of
sexual harassment but also a real
urgency to help victims and to move the
conversation forward it was incredibly
enlightening yeah they all really are
same way they did Nora I was thinking
that too I love what Judd Apatow said
because it does seem like a tsunami of
allegations coming totally over the
place in all different sections and he
said how sad it is that so many women in
so many different areas felt the need to
stay silent for so long thousands and
thousands of women who experienced this
but we are seeing a sort of reckoning
and a seismic shift in terms of how we
see gender and how we see power in this
country around the world I would like to
see how we move on to healing and
reconciliation for second chances do you
overcome it and how do you move on from
here for both men and women yeah and the
question of what happens to people's
careers
after this and the lessons learned by
the next generations coming up
absolutely on boys in particular about
how to be man in the ideas of American
masculinity are really at the core of
all of this really good Alex Philly
extrusion happy to do it